okay so we've taken care of the
conjugate we've taken care of the
negative what's the next one we've had
gotta have a look at here okay so i z
what does i z do well let's think about
the arithmetic first
in rectangle form and then we'll think
about the geometry so
here comes my diagram and
when we take a have a look at the the
actual arithmetic here right
multiplying through by i so this is i z
that i'm calculating we started off with
1 take away
root 3i so when i multiply i
by 1 take away root 3 i let's just do
the number crunching
so you're getting i take away root 3i
squared so you can see this root 3
i squared this is just going to become
negative root 3
and then you're taking away negative
root 3. so watch out for that double
negative
that gives you root 3 plus
i so i've got them in the right order
now what does that look like where is
that
well you can see if i compare that to
the original z that i've got
you're going to be going you know i said
that
let's go back with this color if this is
1
over here then 2 i guess would be here
and root 3 is
about 1.7 in addition to that i've got
this
up here as 1. so if that's my vertical
distance and
this root 3 ish is going to be my
horizontal distance
then root 3 plus i will be about there
there we go right there i z so
ringing a bell hopefully that actually
what we've got here is
a rotation through pi onto radians
anti-clockwise we have gone from down
below
up to here right and that's what's given
us this coordinate up the top
right so therefore what can i say about
the relationship between
these uh these moduli and these
arguments well
yet again the modulus is unchanged you
can see this rotation around the origin
hasn't changed the distances or the
lengths along the hypotenuse of these
right angle triangles
so i'm going to say i z is still going
to start with a 2
and then when i say okay what will the
argument be we'll be the theta
in this case you're going to say oh i
started down here at negative pi on 3
but then i'm going to
add pi on 2 which gets me all the way
into the first
quadrant so i'll write this out in long
form first so i've got
cos of negative pi on 3
plus pi on 2 plus
i sine of negative pi on 3
plus pi on two and
hopefully you can confirm for yourself
either by right angle triangle
trig in in this triangle over here or
just by doing you know this
combination of fractions by getting
common denominators hopefully you can
convince yourself that this is going to
be pi on 6
plus i sine pi
on 6. so you can see here again trying
to generalize right
what happens when you compare z with i z
well the modulus doesn't change it's
still going to be r but what you're
going to have is
cos of your whatever angle whatever you
started with and you're going to add pi
on 2
and then you're going to do the same
with sine theta
plus pi on 2 that that plus pi on 2
highlight it like so that is
the thing you get from multiplying by i
nothing else changes
okay so i hope your brain is going all
right so far we're on the home stretch
for this particular question so it says
z squared and then it goes z to the
power of negative one so let's um
let's tackle each of these in turn and
sort of together because you can see
unlike these guys where you're just sort
of you're multiplying by i you're
multiplying by negative one
all these kinds of things here are not
changing the size of what's going on but
you'll see
for part e and part f there is going to
be a difference
so let's paste it again for good measure
f is asking for z squared
so just like before what i'm going to do
is we'll think about the rectangular
form first
go ahead and simplify and then see what
we can then glean out of that for the
geometry of what's happening
so i've got one take away root 3i
and that's been squared so i'm just
going to expand this out see what
happens right
so i'm going to get this is like you
know in
a plus b or squared form so you can see
i'm going to start with 1 squared which
is 1. i'm going to do my plus 2 a b
which in this case is minus 2
root 3 i and then i'm going to add my b
squared
but just be careful because your b
squared is going to be
let's see here root 3 squared and i
squared
so i'll write that as root 3 i or
squared you can see that along the end
here right that root 3 will
square up into 3 and the i will square
up into
negative 1. so in fact you're going to
have 1
take away 2 root 3i take away
3. so minus 2 minus 2
root 3 i is my summary
so where is this well i've made my axis
a little bit smaller but i think we can
just fit it there right
we're going to go first to the left 2
units so there goes negative 1
there goes negative 2 like so and then
negative 2 root 3. we've already
established that
root 3 is about 1.7 so 2 root 3 would be
our 3.4 so i'm guessing
if this is 1 this is 2 this is 3 so 3.4
is around here so i'm going to draw it
about
that spot so let's go down to what did i
just say
um i lost my my scale so
that's one that's two that's three so
three point four about
there okay i better keep an eye on that
so i didn't lose it okay so
there is where i'm eyeballing that okay
so let's go ahead
make that a little bit straighter there
we go all right so here this number
this point i should say that i've put
down the bottom this is z
squared now what's going on here well
hopefully you can see for starters this
thing is bigger
unlike the moduli that we were having
look at before all the r's were still
two right this moduli modulus was two
so was this one so is this one of course
the original one was
two but here like just by virtue of my
diagram you can see it's longer than two
how much longer is it well if you have a
think about it this way
what you've got here is in fact and i
might even color it just so you can see
what's going on
let's make this a little bit thinner
because it's going to be very thick
this triangle over here that you can see
in the third quadrant
hopefully you can see number one by its
coordinates and also just by the fact
that i've drawn it reasonably well
you can see that it is actually a
similar triangle to the one that we
started
over here with in the fourth quadrant
you see it's just a bigger version and
it's been
you know flipped over so being that it's
similar
i can use its proportions its ratios to
work out the sizes of my sides
you can see this length here is exactly
double over this one
and this vertical length here is also
double compared to this one we have
2 root 3 versus root 3. so therefore the
hypotenuse is also going to be
doubled you can see that that means
we're going to go from 2
up to 4. so this is my new modulus and
of course you could work that out by
pythagoras in this orange triangle if
you like
for now let's just jot that down the
modulus of z
squared will be four and then what about
the angle
well you can also see that i've got a
similar situation happening
as we did up here right in terms of how
the angles will relate to each other the
things that are supplementary and so on
so you can see i've got a negative pine
3 here
which means that i'll also have pi on 3
here but because the argument of this
z-squared down here
starts from the positive side of the
real axis i'm going to need another
color here maybe purple stand out
i've got to start from the positive side
of the real axis and then rotate around
until i get to that that interval that
points me at z
squared right so therefore since this is
pi on three
this over here is going to be negative
two pi on three
that's going to be the angle that i have
there negative two pi
on 3 when i keep its direction in mind
so therefore i can say arg z
will be negative 2 pi on 3. so
now i'm ready to put it all together and
write it as mod arg forms
z squared equals here comes four that's
my new argument
sorry new modulus all the words flying
around and then here comes cos this is
the argument
uh negative two pi on three plus i sine
negative two pi on 3.
okay so there's z-squared now you can
see what's going on here
is because we're multiplying by this
number by itself
you know this action here when we said
we multiply by
a number with a real component and an
imaginary component the real component
scales
right so that's why this is twice as far
away and then the imaginary component
rotates which is why you can see i go
through is negative pi on 3.
well when you multiply a second time
you're scaling up by a factor
two again so that's why you're you're at
four presumably i did it again
you'd be eight and then sixteen and so
on and also because i'm multiplying by
an imaginary component
again i multiply by i rotate rather by
pi on three radians here and then i
rotate another pi and three radians you
can see
here right so this negative two pi and
three is made up of two pieces there's
the first part on three
and then there's the second pile and
three and it's all negative because
you're heading in the
clockwise direction okay last one let's
have a go at
part g what's being asked for is z to
the power of negative 1 which of course
we can think of as 1 over
z all right we'll just have our diagram
here on standby we're going to come to
it shortly but let's work out things in
cartesian form in rectangular form
and see what insights that can yield for
us
now i already have my z defined as 1
take away root
3 i of course i don't really want to
divide through by a complex denominator
so as we've seen before i'm going to
multiply by the conjugate
which is going to realize my denominator
and that's going to give me something
nice and much easier to deal with so
what do we get on the numerator of
course that's just going to be 1 plus
root 3
i and then on the denominator we've got
a difference of squares thing happening
here so this is going to be
1 squared take away root 3 i
squared of course we're about to get a
double negative but we're a bit ahead of
ourselves right
so i've got 1 plus root 3 i on the top
and then i've got 1 plus
because i've got that take away i
squared and then that root 3 squared
just gives me
3. so i'm getting one plus root
three i all divided by four okay
so where is this thing going to be well
let's have a look over here
um if i start to look here and zoom in
real real real real close right
a quarter is going to be well if this is
one
then i can say here's a half and here's
a quarter so things are getting real
small
okay so i will just label that guy as a
quarter
and then we said okay well if this
distance here is root 3
then root 3 over 4 which is going to be
my imaginary component as you can see
here
that's going to be well it's if i had
root 3 being
this tall before it's going to be let's
uh let's do this
so if that's root root 3 or negative 3 i
should say
there's about half and there's about a
quarter so let's put that at the same
spot up here
and i'll stay with the same cost so
there it is there
and we'll draw the dotted lines just for
the sake of completeness
that's going to be 1 over z which is
actually z to the negative 1 that's the
way the question got phrased to us in
the first place
okay so what's going on here this teeny
little complex number
what is happening well if we think back
to
uh z squared which we just did right the
z squared is take z
and then do it again right so you know
you you scaled by a factor of two you
got twice
as far from the origin so you went from
two to four and
you rotated around another time so
previously you went negative pi on three
so now we go negative two pi on three
right so it goes another pi on three
radians
in the clockwise direction that's for
multiplication
but if you're doing division then
everything is reversed so you can see
that instead of going up by a factor of
two you're going to you know here comes
two then four you're actually going to
go
backwards right so you can see things
have gone off in the other direction and
they're not twice as big they're twice
as small we can confirm that just by
thinking about what's going on with mod
arg form here right if i say to myself
oh okay what is the modulus
here well the modulus of z by pythagoras
equals the square root of a which in
this case is a quarter
squared there's a squared plus b squared
which is
root 3 on 4 squared so just simplifying
this out you can see
i'm going to get 1 over 16 plus 3 over
16 underneath my
square root so that's going to be the
square root of 4
over 16 that's the square root of a
quarter
and that's going to be well defined as a
half because don't forget
we're in we're in positive when real
numbers here because the modulus is just
the length
so that length of a half corresponds to
the fact that
you know here this length tells you
instead of getting
twice as big you're getting twice as
small and then what's happening with the
rotation like the real part tells you
about scale so we've just dealt with
that
the imaginary part deals with rotation
well we've already seen this same
argument before
does it look familiar all the way from
this guy here
right it's it's the same rotation that
we've gone up in this direction it's
just that i'm a bit smaller i don't go
all the way up to the conjugate of z
so in fact this is just a small scaled
down version of the conjugated z if you
like
you can see that i'm going in the
opposite direction
over here because instead of going pi on
3 clockwise i'm going to go part
3 anti-clockwise which is positive right
so therefore i can combine my modulus
here which is a half
with my argument argument of
z this z by the way it's sums it to the
negative 1 is what i should say
because this is the original number so
let's write that as negative 1
and this guy here is also negative 1.
so when i work out the argument of z to
the negative 1
it's just going in the opposite
direction right because instead of
you know doing it again which is
multiplying through i'm dividing which
is going backwards so therefore
it's going to be positive pi on 3
double negative there so therefore z to
the power of negative 1 is going to be
here comes my new modulus and then here
comes
cos of pi on 3 plus i sine
pi on 3. so you can see what's going on
here is that you're undoing you're
getting smaller and rotating
clockwise instead of anti-clockwise
that's what 1 over z does
so hopefully you can see um doing these
questions and also having the visual
alongside is very very instructive it
gives you insight as to what's actually
happening
so even when you are not required to
draw i encourage you to get an argand
diagram down
so that you can clearly see the
relationships visually